ah okay so
uh i'm guessing you saw the ad that i
put on uh craigslist
so that would uh your uh
hank marshall 09 at gmail
just hank is fine hank yeah okay all
right pretty
pretty standard roommate questions uh
for you before we do this
um i'd uh you know love to live with
someone who you know
is um pretty clean pretty clean and uh
quiet
uh would you um
would you consider yourself both clean
and quiet
yes very yeah great
great i you know i would have guessed if
i had
you know if i had to guess from looking
at that you're
cleaning
summers summers can get pretty hot in
the city as i'm sure you know
um just wondering uh
does uh hair um
kind of free fall from you
uh from your head and
the rest of it onto the onto the sofa
you know pretty much the entire
apartment
when it's hot
am i gonna have to brush you or no
no okay um
were you uh using the shower
or uh are you more of a
you know lick man yes
yes you're using the shower or yes
you're a lick man
yes i'll be i'll be using the shower i'm
not a
i'm not a lick man no
okay okay it's you know it's just
helpful for us to get these questions
out there
uh one thing that could be a problem
this is a
no pets building i don't know if that's
uh
that's gonna work it's fine i don't have
any pets
yeah but
should be fine
you